[Music]
in I believe I can fly news made by cam
burn from Meridius Chadbourne cam burn
from Meridius Mauritius Mateus Mauritius
sounds like a Greek yes wow I never met
anyone with the name can burn maybe the
name is from a [ __ ] book or something
gem burn of Meridian am other than its
name is amar et was Britain's real life
Iron Man has created a state-of-the-art
flying suit oh I saw this it's so cool
who's the real daredevil Tony Stark over
there some adventure dude I guess like a
British Elan pony Bach this is tight
honey Bach oh there's jets all over the
arms and everything [ __ ] Oh baby
like that so if you have about four
hundred and forty two thousand dollars I
sure do
you can get your own we could chip in
for it we'll get to use it first
um the least sweaty person so I'll use
it last because I swear like a
[ __ ] and I don't wanna I will
break it to ya I don't want to
contaminate it yeah all right so I'm
gonna show you guys a video clip of this
dope as jet soup we're gonna power
why did they shoot on a square camera 4
by 3 ratio ology and they couldn't get
so true okay one exoskeleton suit a
camera that looks cool too obsessed
invent very living above it alone you
feel the weight you go to do a systems
check the heads up display fires up you
squeeze that trigger too
power you feel the thrust come in and
then there's that magic moment when it
all goes peaceful when the ground
retreat needs a bit like riding a bike
but in three dimensions where you have
complete three-dimensional freedom but
what if you got a scratch your head doll
dude littles no no you hit the buddy
little head scratchers come in there's a
hard time avoiding the comparisons extra
500 so we didn't build this to build an
Iron Man suit there were some wonderful
parallels and the CGI community reached
out to us joyously and we're very
excited to see that it turns out that
all of their thinking that they'd done
around what this might be like was
actually really very accurate it's a
great link I love people to make when
they see it gasps da but then you know
the two Jet's on the hand if you move it
up or whatever that's how you control it
huh yeah daddy's alive jet and each of
them are [ __ ] powerful and so pretty
much how they described it [ __ ] power
I mean there's no me to tell you
technicals yeah look for it in this
article Senate and how that prepared for
you guys yeah I'll look it up if I
really want to know how much horse it's
not gonna look it up yes I do I have a
better idea so it pretty much I uses
these engines to blow air out to propel
him above Mecca I'd have to on my butt
cheek one for the right one for the left
and it'll be like a chair cuz that [ __ ]
looked like okay yeah one on his back
and then he was like this well you can't
use your hands man your hands is gonna
[ __ ] push your throat through through
space
how you gonna steer you could steer with
your feet oh your butt cheeks he said
that he tried putting jets on his feet
but it just didn't work out right can
you show me what steering with your pole
look like oh no we can't I can't see
that there's all that stuff what do you
mean oh like if you're sitting if you're
sitting yeah so I'm flexing my right and
I'm pushing to the left and I go this
way
[Music]
but you can't go backwards
yeah how'd it go backwards oh then get a
gin on your chest and you have a jet on
your boat yeah okay that got really
complicated well then you need free
hands cuz I'm a mute I'm assuming that
in the future you know free hands to
shoot to shoot comes with that you
daniels comes their way he's saying that
he it so he did have he did spent some
time in the Royal Marines mm-hmm he
worked and were you ever in the Royal
Marines no that sounds cool and a
regular there nods at Royal well it
sounds cooler than regular marine that's
fine they look they wear funny outfits
but you're not royal
did you wear Berets no that's an army
thing huh what kind of hats do Marines
where we have fun I don't I don't know
the real name is but we call it piss
covers did the captain hat the white
with the looks like so you're right you
have a hat that looks like you work at
in and out you know that one yeah we had
that one and then we have a regular the
cap that we were when we're are camis
and then we have another one that looks
like a cab driver police officer I've
got the NATO hat kind of forgot what
these driver police yeah the captain had
the the yacht a yacht captain had that
kind I forgot the names of the ladies
man some militaries got some goofy a
[ __ ] dude sometimes well I like watching
military parades and [ __ ] some of them
are so outdated when they March
that [ __ ] looks so funny they got the
squiggly eyes swords and [ __ ] I think
it's like the Indian military or
something and then they they kick like a
[ __ ] they're just like linking
arms and [ __ ] like the hyenas in that
the North Korean yeah it's like they're
burlesque [ __ ] dancers and [ __ ]
I'm like damn dude that [ __ ] looks like
some World War one [ __ ] homie they did
it when we saw the pre-elections
burlesque show it was horrible we did
too bad oh no no in France Oh
if France was like artistic [ __ ] I
never knew that I could be moved in such
a way through [ __ ] titties and [ __ ]
yeah it was a fine wine [ __ ] it's
different aged out here I feel like
we're in and out [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
made-to-order
real good quality but affordable BAM and
you get full and you get you enjoy out
there it's like it's like five-course
[ __ ] many emotions many many I never
knew I could be sad and horny at the
same time it was a dope that's I mean
usually when I'm horny I'm pretty sad
yeah really well I'm in a long-distance
relationship oh no any more no she's
still out there
oh really yeah long-distance marriage
anyway back to this flying suit here so
no backs of [ __ ] nom squad that was
amazing
doula some shows that I had an emotional
experience when I was watching and it
was just the dance and the movements
made me go through a roller coaster of
Oh
about to see some [ __ ] and then oh
that's a nice [ __ ] and then you spin
around and it's like whoa look at those
legs Wow what okay cover it up because
you ain't that kind of girl that's an
ass cheek that's an ass cheek your eyes
going [ __ ] by the way oh you're always
cuffed he was looking for [ __ ] oh you
know you ever like look for something
when you go like are you trying to
[ __ ] look for dear life and you're
moving you're so surprised cuz they're
like spread they're like so why I'm like
how does it not like that's the point of
like the big bird doesn't get stretched
out sometimes isn't like the point of
burlesque is to like so everything but
like all like almost show everything
yeah yeah where was the one you guys
went to that was whack he was out I'm
out [ __ ] Hollywood for there oh yeah
it was like a hipster Barney it was like
everyone everyone's oh man like to get
horny thing I see I see
yeah but threw up every time it's like
it's a confidence building burlesque
show for them it's like it's like if if
people were really overweight in
handicap but they want to feel sexy they
go to the burlesque show and they think
they're sexy and everyone's giving them
[ __ ] pity claps that's the cut only
Monday nights but cuz it was called like
Monday night whatever but I'm wondering
like in the weekends and they actually
have some legit confident like a bbw
strip club for so long just for like
nothing but big girls it's got to be hot
I like hot big girls but in this case
they weren't the hot kind they weren't
pretty you guys don't want to talk about
this Jetson I do I think it's they look
like caterpillars from the [ __ ] Alice
Alice in Wonderland it's all let's go
back to this boring ass [ __ ] what's
going I'm jealous because I don't have
one
yeah he's gotta sell JK dammit we can't
pull our money it's four hundred
thousand pounds or $400 dollars in
pounds is hmm three hundred and forty
thousand pounds
Oh what is it it's gonna be available
for civilian sales apparently it is
already yeah but I went on the website
that they say where it's available and I
didn't see it sorry
that's price just know you got to go to
the Home Shopping Network and what
exists yeah it's big food no but this
thing is so dope so they actually broke
a world record they this suits can go up
to 32 miles per hour
Wow that's [ __ ] best and at altitudes
of 12,000 feet oh my god are you serious
can't even breathe up there yeah buddy
birthday I have a mess
what's the safety feature let's say like
one of your jets blow out do you have
like a little parachute hopefully it
doesn't get like a douchey connotation
like the air board's like the
hoverboards did
those were so fun until all the miners
like me there were douchey I think they
were just kind of whack no there's so
look stupid okay so there's this
grown-ass person going yeah and your
[ __ ] arm thing you're like doing the
[ __ ] you know hand talk to you that's
them I think it's stupid you trying to
take out the trash and they see me you
think I'm stupid
no I'm like everyday what do I say about
him every time I see her she says you're
super cool no I don't say that you know
what I say what do you mean you listen
she says you're a homosexual I just said
it on Monday said super dope oh I said
he's genius are you having to take out
the trash as well alright its genius its
genius that's what I say about UB Choi I
do listen and for the record I already
told us a million times guys don't
understand all those multiple emotions I
just it is I only understand it's that
positive or negative you know recently
like when we when we get upset at each
other before I used to go are you mad at
me or are you upset are you frustrated
and so now I don't even know what all
those things mean I just go are you
negative at me it's all-encompassing
because for girls each one of those is
one thing right but for me it's just
like oh she acting like a [ __ ] again
but girls could be [ __ ] for so many
reasons yeah so I just go
are you negative at me are you negative
at me but you should know instead of
that you should say what's the thing
that I did that caused you to feel
negative oh that's the second hand what
if she's just having a bad day I have to
figure that out first
are you negative at me and if she is
that I'm okay cool can I do to change it
or if she's just having a bad day and
she's not negative at me but she was
negative about herself then I approach
that differently too but I don't
understand frustrated anger upset oh
yeah I don't understand you Dee bro
sometimes just in a bad mood you know
you never feel that you never
not me really I've never caught me moody
never that's what I'm saying to you I
don't know that's what I'm saying I'm
like I don't think I'm from moon does
get moody does we do we just unaware of
it he is moody I am I'm a moody you do
get my window I get movie just unaware
of it it exists
I know because sometimes I [ __ ] open
my eyes up to the world and I say oh I'm
irritated and I'm taking out my
frustration on people yeah
Byam [ __ ] a matrix yeah [ __ ] I'm
learning
[Music]
[Music]